una vez más las calles de melbourne
vacías una semana después de salir del
quinto confinamiento la variante delta
envió nuevamente a los residentes a sus
casas el gobernador del estado de
victoria dan andrews dijo que se
encontraba maniatado al tomar la medida
no puedo describir lo decepcionado que
estoy al tener que hacer esto nuevamente
pero con tan pocos en la comunidad con
una dosis de la vacuna mucho menos dos
literalmente no tengo otra opción que
aceptar el consejo y tomar esta
importante decisión para mantener a los
victorianos seguros
el jueves se reportaron ocho nuevos
casos en melbourne y en el resto del
estado de victoria
andrews culpó al estado vecino de nueva
gales del sur de haber tardado demasiado
en cerrar su capital sydney la ciudad
reportó 262 contagios comunitarios y 5
muertes del jueves el peor día en casi
seis semanas de confinamiento el
gobernador victoriano insistió en que la
vacunación es clave para vencer a la
variante belta
un chico en sus veintes murió ayer en
sydney esto no es algo que solo está
pasando al otro lado del mundo no es
algo que solo le pasa a gente mayor
frágil esto nos puede pasar a cualquiera
por eso vacunarse es tan importante
australia tiene una tasa relativamente
baja de contagios de coronavirus pero
con menos del 20 por ciento de la
población completamente vacunada hay
miedo que la variante cause mayores
estragos